[Musique]
chantal goya est ce que vous vous êtes
déjà dit le prochain qui me parle du jeu
de la vérité je les mets une grosse
patate je crois que prochain je vais le
faire mais comment tu as vécu ce jeu de
la vérité
que j'ai fait c'est si longtemps j'ai
inventé reality show commence c'est vrai
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit si je
retrouve cette [ __ ] d'institutrice je
lui défense la gueule est ce que vous
êtes déjà dit bon j'aime pas les enfants
mais tant pis non non je les adore est
ce que vous êtes déjà dit il boit
d'accord mais bon il fait de bonnes
chansons quand même il n'est pas
alcoolique jean jacques et moi parce
qu'il aime le bon vin mais il voit
jamais le matin jamais à midi et si je
dîne avec une soirée boit pas génial
mais ce serait
incroyable vous êtes déjà d'y aller
après tout mon mac est en prison
non au bout de ma rue en plus vous êtes
déjà dit il est quand même bien gaulée
le capitaine flam kivu non le vrai
que c'est moi
vous êtes déjà dit non 5 dans un seul
lycée trop puis ça fait quand même
quelques ya pas de mathématiques service
j'ai déjà dit chanteuse sait peut-être
pas mon truc finalement
sanex fois parce que saisissent pas
parti pour être chanteuse ça se voit non
mais je sais moi même parce que
j'aimerais bien chanter un peu mieux
vous êtes déjà dit j'ai envie de mourir
là
oui je peux mourir mais ma grande entité
qu'est ce qu'on va faire de moi ou
est-ce que chanson non ce matin à
les céder mais quand ça n'est pas m que
tout le monde disait maurice qu'on va la
mettre et c'était une horreur j'ai déjà
dit allez hop ma grosse au régime oui
oui quand parce qu'il ya trois ans j'en
ai six jeunes essayer une robe et la
vendeuse elle m'a dit vous inquiétez pas
quand vous aurez fait votre bébé sayan
lara vous ira mieux mais non c'est mon
bide alors dont crescenzo talons rentrer
dare midi mais décontracté vous vous
êtes déjà dit et si je me faisais
refaire les seins non non pas du tout
ils vont très bien au moins un essai
je ne voulais pas qu'il fait pas l'eau
certains mois et vont bien
vous êtes déjà dit [ __ ] mais qu'est ce
que je fous queen à trois heures du
matin avec tous ces connards en train de
chanter barbara n'ont pas tous ces
connards mais des fois je me dis il est
4 heures du matin j'ai toujours pas
chanter ils sont tous comme des fous
j'ai payé une balle je ne venais pas là
je commence à m'endormir va voir ça va
être catastrophique
et ben non j'ai la pêche et djibril
fonds papa ballon à trente deux ans à
vous si vous fait pas flipper ça non pas
du tout c'est moi c'est non ça veut dire
que je suis leur père de leur enfant
c'est ça me fait un beau cadeau mais tu
nous as vu tout à l'heure remarque
chantal goya
c'est d'éviter chez jacques dans les
grands éditeurs et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu